A couple of announcements.
The contest ends today 5:00.
Get the email to my address.
Wednesday will be the test,
Test 1, and I will say a few words
about that, coverage through the end
of lecture on Wednesday.
What I am talking about today,
I will not be testing you, but maybe
you might pay attention because
about a month from now we will ask
you a few skill testing
questions about it.
But it's one of those pedagogical
things. If I test right up until
the last thing I say,
I don't think that gives you enough
dwell time. The flip side is there
are going to be a couple of lectures
now where it is not going to be on
the test, so I think you will deal
with it. Monday I will be giving a
seminar on engineering education in
Halifax, so in my place will be
Professor Ballinger who will
competently substitute for me and
keep the ball rolling.
But I will be back Tuesday.
And you can contact me if you have
some questions in connection with
the material. First thing,
I will begin with comments about the
test. And that way we won't have to
worry about running out of time at
the end. The test is Wednesday the
29th, and it will be written during
the normal class time.
So if you take the test at 11:00
come here, but there is a plurality
of rooms because we want to have
some vacancies here.
If your last name begins A through
Ke, you will come to this room.
If your last name begins Kh through
Ya, you go to 50-340.
That is the gymnasium on the third
floor of Walker.
There is a gym up on the third
floor and will accommodate a couple
hundred people there.
And for those of you at the very end
of the alphabet,
we have a special room for you,
1-190, so everybody has some elbow
room. Please go to the assigned
room. And, by all means,
if you are scheduled to attend class
at 11:00, please take the test at
11:00. Don't all come crashing into
1:00 because we don't have the room
or the number of exams.
So please go to the assigned room.
Here is what the mechanics are.
You are going to just go to the room,
as you normally do,
come on in, sit down.
That's all you have to do,
just sit down. What is the purpose
of the test, by the way?
Why do I give you a test?
It is to give you a status report.
I want to give you some feedback to
tell you how you are doing soon.
There are two messages I can give
you.
Either keep up the good work or you
better change your strategy because
you are not mastering the material.
That is all I am trying to do. I
am not trying to run a cross-check
on the admissions process.
As I told you, I believe that
everybody that is in this room has
the intellectual apparatus to pass
this class, so there is no
gamesmanship here.
If you have been investing in the
time that I have asked you to,
you will pass handily. There are no
tricks.
You can look at old exams,
you can look at your homework,
that's the kind of questions you can
expect. Nothing to broadside you.
On the other hand, if you haven't
been keeping up,
I hope that you won't pass so I can
tell you, look,
you have to do things differently.
That's all. Bring five things with
you. You have five fingers,
five things. Periodic Table,
Table of Constants, and you are
allowed an aid sheet,
an 8-1/2 by 11 sheet of paper.
You can write anything you want on
it. You can write on the front.
You can write on the back.
You can write on the edge.
I don't care. You can photocopy.
You can photo-reduce. You can take
everything from the last ten years
of 3.091 and make it microdots.
I don't care. Whatever you want.
That is three, Periodic Table,
Table of Constants,
aid sheet. Something to calculate
with. There will be some
computations, so something to
calculate with.
And I don't care if it is a
programmable calculator.
The only thing is no wireless
devices. This has wireless
Internet here.
You are not going to be sending
emails during and exam.
No wireless devices. And Lord help
you if a cell phone goes off.
And last thing, something to write
with. And, believe it or not,
I have students walk in and first
thing a hand goes up and says do you
have a pen? I cannot believe it.
Make sure you have batteries that
are in a good state of charge in
your calculator.
We don't have 450 calculators for
you. And you will write.
We will give you the question paper.
You just fill in on the paper,
hand it in. You don't have to bring
any paper. We will start you at
00:05 and we will stop you at 00:55.
Stop when we ask you to stop out of
courtesy to your classmates.
Everybody might like a little more
time. But 00:55 you stop and we
will have people collect them either
down here or at the back.
And we will get you out of here in
an orderly fashion.
So that is the mechanics.
Now, strategy. I want you to do
well.
I want you to be able to put your
best foot forward.
I don't want you to get all
frustrated and fail to show what you
know, so here are a couple of tips.
First thing, read the test. That
comes as a big shock.
A lot of people don't read the test.
They just open it up,
and they just start working.
There's going to be, I don't know,
four or five questions. Well, I
just put them down in the order that
came out of my head.
I don't put them in any strategic
order. I don't put hardest
first, easiest first.
I don't even think they are in
chronological order by topic.
I think it is just whatever. I
said, well, let's do something on,
I don't know, pick a topic. What
are we asking you?
I cannot remember.
They are all made up and ready to
go. But pick a topic.
Pick something about the Periodic
Table. Maybe that's number one.
But maybe that is not your strong
suit, so don't start on number one.
But you don't know that there is an
easy one for you down at number four
if you haven't bothered to look at
number four. So take a couple
minutes and read the entire test.
And zoom on the easiest question for
you, that way two things happen.
First of all, you build some
confidence. Secondly,
you settle your nerves and then move
in ascending order.
The second thing is try every
question because I give part marks.
It's not all about the number. I
only give, I don't know,
about 10% or 20% for getting the
right number in a computation.
I tell my graders, if the student
demonstrates minimal acceptable
proficiency that student has to get
a passing score.
If it is out of nine,
it has to be five out of nine.
If it is out of ten, it has to be
five out of ten.
If the student hasn't mastered the
basic concept,
we will make sure that the grade
scheme gives a failing grade.
So if you demonstrate something by
writing an intelligent answer just
by outlining it and saying,
well, what I would do is I would
equate the energy and then solve for
lambda, I can see that you know what
is going on. I can give five,
seven out of ten for that.
And then the person who actually
plugs in all the numbers and gets
the right number will get ten.
But if you say, well, I don't know
how to do this,
I am not going to bother,
don't grade the paper. I will grade
the paper. I have some people that
say I am not doing this well,
oh, forget it. No, keep going.
Keep going. And leave tracks.
Write your thoughts.
You don't have to write everything
in equations. You can give me an
outline how to solve.
Work parametrically to the greatest
extent possible.
Let's say you have to go through
three or four operations to get a
final number, well,
do it algebraically.
I have some people, as soon as they
see it, oh, they have the frequency
here. Oh, E equals h nu.
I will plug in. E equals h nu,
so I plug in. I look up h and plug
in 6.6 times 10 to the minus 34.
They plug it in and make a
keystroke error right off the bat.
They got some number that looks
like for the wavelength they got the
distance from here to Chicago,
and they are going to drag that
through the whole calculation.
What are you doing that for?
Conservation of keystrokes. Don't
touch the calculator until the last
line. Work parametrically,
because I can grade easily. I can
look at that and go she knows what
is going on, eight out of ten.
Boom, we are done. You got the
wrong number, forget it.
She has a good grasp of the
material. Instead,
right off the bat you have some
stupid number and you are dragging
that through the calculations.
You have negative wavelengths.
You have square root of minus one
for something else. Focus.
Answer the question.
Don't play games with me.
If I am talking something about the
Bohr model and you start giving me
some core dump about what you know
about the Bohr model,
it doesn't go by the pound.
I have read an entire page full of
words and given it zero because it
is not on topic.
Just be surgical,
give me the answer and move on.
But don't start snowing me. My
graders are smart,
smarter than you. They are.
I have smart graders.
Do your own work,
I mean it. Do your own work.
Here we are terrorists. Keep your
eyes on your own paper.
I don't want to see anybody like
this. If I see that,
I will just go up and reseat you.
And, by the way, if you ever feel
that you are in a compromising
position, someone is pressuring you
for information,
just raise your hand and ask to be
reseated. We don't ask any
questions. As far as we know,
the person next to you has BO. Just
take yourself out of the situation.
And, by the way,
this business on working on every
problem is important because I have
seen some people who start working
on number one,
but that is not their strong suit.
Let's say you have four questions,
you have 50 minutes, take out five
minutes to read the paper,
so that's 45 minutes. That's
roughly 10, 11 minutes per question.
There are some questions that might
be a different length.
You spend 10 minutes on number one
and haven't solved it yet.
Well, another five more minutes.
That's 15 minutes. Now they are
getting steamed.
It's 20 minutes into the exam and
you are still working on number one.
And then they get really angry and
say I am going to solve this if it
is the last thing I do.
Sure enough 11:55 comes,
it is the last thing they are doing.
Now, think about the math. Let's
do the math here.
Suppose there is an epiphany at
11:54 and you get a perfect score on
that question and it is worth 25% of
the paper. You get 25 out of 25,
terrific. You got zero on the rest
because you didn't write anything.
You see what I'm saying? Try all
the questions.
And good luck.
I mean. There is no attempt to
deceive. Come prepared and you will
do fine. And our goal is to grade
those things and get them back to
you the following day.
We give a rapid turnaround.
And we will post the model
solutions. And there will be a
different exam in the afternoon,
but I think it only makes sense for
you not to discuss the paper with
people that are taking it in the
afternoon. We're trying to run a
school here that has some
professional standards.
And there will be plenty of
information on the website and
whatnot. All right.
Well, let's get on with the lesson
today. Just to refresh our memories,
last day we looked at the average
valence electron energy as a measure
of reactivity.
And en route we discovered that we
can divide the Periodic Table into
metals, which is about 75% of the
Periodic Table.
These have low average valence
electron energies.
Which means that these elements are
very good electron donors.
And up in the other extreme are
elements with very high average
valence electron energy.
These are electron acceptors.
They cling to their electrons quite
tenaciously. And,
subsequently, we looked at
photoelectron spectroscopy which is
a technique that allows us to
determine binding energies,
ionization energies being just one
example. But we will see later on
that PES can give us other important
information that we
cannot calculate.
And then, towards the end of the
lecture, we started looking at
reactivity. And we put up this
hypothesis that our observation is
that octet stability seems to be an
attractive electron configuration.
So we saw the Noble gases. And then
we said you can also achieve octet
stability and electron transfer if
you look at elements that are just a
little bit rich of electrons versus
octet stability or a little
bit lean of electrons.
And so we got to ionic bonding.
And I think we just got to the
point where we were able to start
looking at the energetics of that.
And we ran out of time so I want to
resume that. I think I had managed
to get to this point here where I
show what happens when the cation,
here sodium, is in contact with the
anion here, chlorine.
And we reasoned that these two
eventually reach some kind of an
equilibrium separation which we are
using lowercase r to represent.
This is the separation measured from
the center of the sodium nucleus.
And there is this separation which
is a balance of attractive forces
because the chloride is net negative
and the sodium is net positive,
but both of them, regardless of net
charge, have electrons.
And so when they become very,
very closely spaced there is mutual
repulsion of those electrons.
And so there is a repulsive term
here.
And so the balance of the attractive
term and the repulsive term
eventually leads us to this
situation where we have the
equilibrium spacing.
And this equilibrium spacing is
denoted r sub zero or r naught.
And r naught really is nothing more
than the sum of the ionic radius of
sodium and the ionic radius of
chloride. So we could just say r
plus plus r minus gives you r naught.
And right off the bat you notice
that I am making a huge
assumption here.
I am modeling the ions as hard
spheres. I am modeling them as
billiard balls of a finite dimension.
And so they eventually reach this
equilibrium position.
And we saw last day that we have a
Coulombic force of attraction which
you have seen before.
Cation is plus one, anion is minus
one. But it doesn't have to be.
This could be magnesium. Magnesium
would be 2 plus,
so in here you would put 2e.
Or I could have an oxide here,
so I would put minus 2e.
In this case we just have one and
one. And then the repulsive term,
some positive coefficient and r to a
very high number.
N lies between 6 and 12,
and this is known as the Born
exponent. And this is a very high
number because it depends upon
electron-electron repulsion.
These electrons, first of all,
there are many of them. And they
are in motion and moving at very,
very high speed. And so the result
is that this repulsive term
is very, very intense.
But very short order.
Beyond a modest distance you don't
feel the electron-electron repulsion.
So you need the mathematics to
imitate reality.
And that is why this is such a high
number. And down here,
what do we have? We have the sum of
these two bottoming out.
See, at very, very high values of r,
one over r dominates.
At very, very low values of r,
one over r to the 10th dominates.
And in between the two cancel, and
here we are at the minimum.
And we can find r naught by looking
for the minimum.
How do we get the minimum?
We differentiate dE by dr. We take
dE by dr equals zero at r equals r
naught. And, coincidently,
what is the partial of energy with
respect to distance?
That is force. So what am I saying?
The net force is zero.
Attractive and repulsive forces are
balanced. So everything
makes sense here.
And we can solve this.
And, if we do so, we can actually
get a handle on that Born exponent
by solving the equation.
And I am not going to do it.
I am just going to put it up here
without taking time.
And so what I get is the energy of
the system at the equilibrium
separation is given by minus z plus.
This is the most general form.
This is the valence,
the charge on the cation times --
I will common factor this.
The charge on the cation times e.
The charge on the anion times minus
e, so there is the minus e squared,
and divided by 4 pi epsilon zero r
naught, because now I am evaluating
this function at r naught,
one minus one over n where n is the
Born exponent.
And this applies only at,
obviously, r equals r naught.
But that is good because that is the
equilibrium separation.
So that tells us the energy of what?
What have I formed here?
I formed a bond, an ionic bond.
So this is the energy of a single
ionic bond.
And what do we notice?
We notice that the value of E at r
naught is negative,
as it should be. It's a negative
number. And what are the
characteristics of this bond.
Well, there are two things that I
want to highlight.
First of all, it is omnidirectional.
What do I mean by that?
There is no preferred direction.
It could form in any direction
because the Coulombic field is
radial in all directions.
There is no preferred orientation.
The field is radial. This is the
electric field.
So there is no preferred direction.
And the second thing is it is
unsaturated. What do I mean by that?
Well, I show you one sodium and one
chloride. There is nothing saying
that that sodium,
its positive charge has not been
neutralized. It still has positive
charge, and there is nothing saying
another chloride could not stick to
it. We get another chloride and
another sodium sticking to the
chloride. This means it is not a
strict bond one-to-one.
It is not monogamous is another way
of putting it.
It allows for plurality of bonds
from any ion. Plurality of bonds
can form from any ion.
And, if you take all of these ideas,
omnidirectional and unsaturated,
it means that ions can keep glomming
on. And that result is we get large
arrays of ions. Well,
what does give us?
Well, if I have a large number of
species glommed together that means
it is going to be solid at room
temperature because gases exist as
discrete particles.
We have either single atoms or
molecules consisting of small
numbers of atoms.
You don't have gas molecules
consisting of thousands of atoms.
When it gets to thousands of atoms
things start to condense because
there is a capacity to form other
bonds secondarily,
which we will get to in a little bit.
So just take it on faith.
If you have a large number of atoms
in an aggregate,
it is going to require that the
substance turn solid and condense at
room temperature.
And word array is loaded.
These don't just sit down anywhere.
They sit down in a special way.
And so what you're going to end up
with is, well,
let's go over that.
Here is sodium and chloride.
They keep attaching and attaching
and attaching, but
we have two sizes.
We are modeling them as hard spheres.
And so they are going to fit
together in a regular array.
And so this means that they will
form a crystal.
So we are going to have solids and
we are going to have crystal.
And what do we mean by crystal?
Crystal is an ordered solid, as
opposed to a disordered solid.
And we will talk about both in a
little bit. Now I want to show you
that this comes necessarily from an
energetic standpoint.
It is a really cool derivation.
I want to compare two situations.
Here is an ion gas. This is my
humble drawing to indicate discrete
sodium chlorine pairs.
This is one of these pairs that I
have shown up here.
It has a negative energy.
We see that we get a negative
energy by attaching the chloride to
the sodium. And I am saying suppose
these form, as they have to
initially, in the gas phase.
And they remain two atoms per ion
pair discretely bombing around in
the gas phase.
That is situation number one.
Situation number two is I take the
same number, and I make a row.
They are all in one row. So what
happens? I have only drawn three,
but now let's pump up the volume.
Here, let's get N Avogadro.
If I have Avogadro number of these
things in a long line,
you can bet it is going to be a
solid. It's going to be a
one-dimensional crystal.
The question is can I show you,
from an energetic standpoint, that
the crystal is favored over having
the discrete set of pairs?
And you know the answer is yes
because I wouldn't set myself up for
failure like this,
would I? So let's take a look.
First of all, situation number one,
well, you know how to do that.
Because you know the energy of one
pair. So let's just multiply that
by Avogadro's number.
E1 will simply equal N Avogadro
times the energy of the ion pair at
r equals r naught,
which we can then substitute N
Avogadro. I am doing this for plus
one minus one like sodium chloride.
We can make it more complex later.
And you have to get N from
experimental evidence.
You cannot pull that out of theory.
The Born exponent is determined
experimentally,
and there are tables of that.
Now let's get the energy for the
line. For that I am going to draw a
line of these.
All right. So here is the sodium
and the chloride on each side,
and then we will go for another
sodium and another chloride
on each side.
And so now what I want to do is
start here at the center.
And I am going to count the
energetics. And what I am going to
do is say start with this ion,
add up the energy associated with
the interactions between that ion
and everybody else in the row and
then multiply it by Avogadro's
number, because that is the number
of atoms there are in a row.
Sauce for the goose is sauce for
the gander. You say,
yeah, what about edge effects?
I got Avogadro's number of these
things.
What do you think the error is going
to be by failing to recognize that
at the end of 6 times 10 to the 23rd
I have over-counted some energy?
It is vanishingly small. So don't
get preoccupied by the end.
Work the big middle. And the
middle is everything here.
So we can start. This distance
here is r naught.
I know the energy in this first
pair would equal --
That is just going to equal minus e
squared over 4 pi epsilon zero r
naught. That is just what we have
seen before. But,
in addition, the field is continuing
to radiate so it is unsaturated and
it is omnidirectional.
This cation feels the repulsive
force of the cation over here.
This cation is attracting the
chloride next to it and it is
repelling the sodium as the
next nearest neighbor.
So that is a repulsive term.
I have to add that up. I have got
to put that in because that is a
repulsive energy and that is going
to decrease the energy of the system.
So I have a distance here of 2 r
naught. And at a distance of 2 r
naught, I have a positive repulsive
term. I just plug into the
Coulomb's Law.
And so that is going to be plus e
squared over 4 pi epsilon
zero 2 r naught.
Now what happens?
Let's keep counting.
Now the next one is the chloride.
It is of opposite charge and it
exerts an influence,
only that is minus to plus so that
is going to give me a minus term
here. That's 4 pi epsilon zero 3 r
naught and so on and so on.
I think you can see the way this is
going. Well, what about the Born
term? Forget the Born term.
The Born term is not going to be
felt, except in this first one.
I am going to forget it now, and
then I will patch it in at the end.
You don't need Born repulsion at 2 r
naught. That is a waste of memory.
Then what are we going to do? I am
only counting in one direction,
so I have to multiply this whole
thing by two because I have to count
both directions.
Now I am going to common factor
this and will get minus e squared
over 4 pi epsilon zero r naught
times two, times this series,
one minus one-half plus one-third
minus one-quarter, etc.
So this series is broken into two
terms that are conveniently
representing two physical ideas.
This is electrostatics right here.
The pre-factor embodies all the
electrostatics.
And what is all this stuff?
Y is at one, one-half, one-third?
This is the instant geometry. That
is to say the instant
atom arrangement.
In this case it is a line.
Now what I am going to do,
this is off of just that one central
cation. So now let's do it for all
of the ions. What I am going to do
now is I am going to multiply by N
Avogadro and then add
Born repulsion.
And we put all that together and
here is what it looks like.
It looks like. E equal to minus N
Avogadro e squared over 4 pi epsilon
zero r naught,
one minus one over n.
And I am going to call this whole
geometric factor here,
I am going to put it into one number,
and I am going to denote that the
Madelung constant.
The Madelung constant is simply the
geometric factor.
That is a number.
Let's put that there.
And so now the question is,
what I am trying to prove to you is
that E2 is more negative than E1.
So, ultimately, what I want is what
is the relative magnitude of E2 over
E1? What is it?
Is it greater than one?
That's the question. If I can
prove that it is greater than one
that means that the line is more
stable than the set of ion pairs.
And if you look at this series,
the series log of one, what is the
series expansion?
Log of one plus x,
what is it? It is x minus x squared
over two plus x cubed over three,
etc. If you plug in x equals one
that is our series.
One minus one-half plus one-third,
it is all there. If you go and work
that out, log of two and you have
two log two, by math you can show
that for the line r series m is
equal to two natural log of two,
which is 1.386 which is greater than
one.
So what have I shown?
I have shown that by taking
Avogadro's number of individual ion
pairs and putting them all together
in a line, the system's energy
became more negative.
So that is to say that it is
favored. We could say an
energy level diagram --
This would be energy.
Here is zero. If this is the
energy of the pair,
let's make this E over E of the ion
pair, so this is one,
and we have just shown that for the
line, so this is Avogadro's number
of pairs, this is Avogadro's number
of ion pairs in a line,
that is 1.386. And then,
if you go the real sodium chloride
crystal and you do this same
calculation but in three-dimensions.
So that you take every sodium and
you count all of its nearest
neighbors, next nearest neighbors,
next next nearest neighbors, not
only on a line but in the plane and
above and below in all three
dimensions and go through that
calculation, it is even more
negative. It is 1.
475. Conclusion: if I start to
react sodium with chlorine,
the result is a crystal, a
three-dimensional array.
Because at every point the first
thing happens is electron transfer.
Why? To get a stable octet. The
result, I've got ion pairs.
Pluses attract to minuses, minuses
attract to pluses.
They start glomming together,
but they don't stop with one plus
one. One plus one and then an ion
pair grabs another one,
another one. And, before you know
it, you have crystal.
So this is simply the energetics of
crystal formation.
This is a three-dimensional crystal.
You can consider this line a
one-dimensional crystal
because it is ordered.
So I would call it a one-dimensional
crystal. This says that when it
comes to ions line-dancing trumps
ballroom dancing.
That is what it is saying.
They would rather be in a line than
dance two-by-two.
That doesn't apply to all things,
but it does in this case. Now let's
look at properties.
Let's talk about properties.
See, we've gone a long way. We
started with this hypothesis of
octet stability and I'm talking
about properties of ionic crystals.
They are solid at room temperature.
Why? What are the bonds? These
are huge energies,
Coulombic forces, high melting
points and boiling points.
Why do they have a high melting
point and boiling point?
Because, when you ask yourself that
question, you should consider what
is the thermal energy versus the
bonding energy?
If the bonding energy is very
strongly negative,
thermal energy isn't great enough to
disrupt those bonds and allow those
bonds to be broken and
then have fluidity.
So strong bonds means high melting
points and boiling points.
Transparent to visible light.
A sodium chloride crystal is
transparent to visible light.
I know table salt is white, but
that is because you have power and
you have multiple surfaces
scattering, but a large crystal of
sodium chloride is clear and
colorless. And it is faceted.
You can see that it has the shape.
If you take one of those individual
grains of sodium chloride,
look at it carefully, you will see
the edges look like this.
Why is it transparent to visible
light? Here is how you ask that
question. When you want to know if
something is transparent to visible
light or not, here is the mystery
material and here is visible light.
And what is going to allow for
absorption or some interaction with
visible light?
Inside here you have electronic
states.
And you have to ask yourself is the
energy difference here,
the delta E in the electronic states,
how does that compare with the E of
visible light?
What is the E of visible light?
You know it is about two to three
electron volts.
This has what? Sodium plus.
It is isoelectronic with neon.
Chloride minus. Isoelectronic with
argon. What do we know about the
average valence electron energies?
We just saw it in the first slide.
It is up around 13,
14, 15 electron volts.
This thing is not going to touch it.
It won't lay a glove on it.
So what happens? It goes through.
Nothing. All that glitters is not
gold, but it must have free
electrons. This has no free
electrons. They are all bound.
That is how you determine if
something is transparent.
It is going to be electrical
insulators. There are no electrons
to move around.
They are all bound,
hard and brittle. Why?
Because they have strong bonds.
Strong bonds means the material will
resist and applied force.
You apply a force and the material
will resist it until you have a
force great enough to break the
bonds. So you don't have ductility,
which is what you have in metal.
That is what makes metal so
fascinating, because metallic
bonding allows the atoms to glide
over one another without resulting
in catastrophic failure.
Whereas, ceramics, ionic crystals
will resist until they shatter.
There are only two categories.
It is either elastic with full
resistance or destruction.
Again, the bonds soluble in water.
Other polar solids, we will have to
come back to that later.
They melt to form ionic liquids.
Ionic solids form ionic liquids. I
showed you last day what happens
when they form and we were able to
electrolyze and make fantastic
metals like magnesium.
Where do we find these ionic
crystals? Where do we look?
Well, you need electron transfer.
You need a donor and you need an
acceptor. So where are the good
donors? Donors are over here,
the metals on the left end of the
Periodic Table.
And where are the acceptors?
On the right side of the Periodic
Table. If you take some from column
one or two and you mix it with some
from column eight and nine,
bingo, you have reaction. Here is
an example that shows some very,
very metallic elements, groups one
and two, and some non-metallic
elements over here,
five, six and seven.
And so you can imagine that if you
mix these, if you take sodium and
you mix it with chlorine
you get sodium chloride.
But there is nothing saying you
cannot take magnesium and mix it
with oxygen and make magnesium oxide.
And you would expect that that
would be a much stabler compound
because, instead of plus one
attracting plus one,
now you have plus two attracting
minus two. So the Coulombic forces
are much, much greater.
And that will be reflected in what?
Higher melting point.
Higher boiling point.
Greater resistance to reactivity.
Does it strike you odd that maybe
magnesium oxide,
one of its applications would be
refractories? That is to say brick
work in high temperature furnaces,
maybe tiles on the Shuttle, to
resist high temperatures because of
the high internal bonding.
You see, there is a system here.
Chemistry isn't a litany of facts.
We started out with a few simple
assumptions and look at what we are
doing now. We are designing systems,
building engineering systems,
making materials choices. It is
fantastic. We can do this one more
time. Let's do it one more time.
I want to show you something else.
I want to show you another way to
get a sense of these energies.
And for that I want to look at the
energy starting from real material.
See, up until now I have been
talking about gas phase,
single atoms, all this stuff.
Let's look at this reaction.
Sodium solid plus chlorine gas.
It is a diatomic molecule.
And I want that to react to give me
sodium chloride as a solid and
crystal. **Na (s) + 1/2 Cl2 (g) --
NaCl (s, xtal)** I want an ordered
solid. For this I need to invoke a
couple of bits of science.
First one is Hess' Law. Hess' Law
states that for any chemical
reaction, the energy change
is path independent.
That is to say I can now reroute
that sodium plus chlorine reaction
and go a different way,
but I still end up with the same
change in energy.
Why? It is because it is state
function. It is the same thing as
gravitational energy.
Whether you take the elevator to
the top of the Hancock Tower or
whether you walk up the stairs,
the change in gravitational
potential is identical.
You might be winded doing it the
second way, but when you get to the
top and you are at the 60th story
your gravitational potential is
independent of how you got there.
And that is what this is saying.
It is analogy. Energy change is
path independent.
Now I am going to break this into
elementary steps and look at the
relative contributions.
What did we do so far? We talked
about this reaction here where we
had chloride ion in the gas phase
plus sodium ion in the gas phase.
We started with gaseous sodium to
make gaseous sodium ion and gaseous
atomic chlorine to make gaseous
chloride ion through
electron transfer.
All the gas phase.
Very idealistic, but that's not the
way the world works.
I want to get to there starting
from real sodium and real chlorine.
The first thing I am going to do is
I am going to convert the sodium
into vapor. This is sodium going to
sodium gas. And then I am going to
take sodium gas and I am going to
make this into sodium gas plus
electron. Oh,
by the way. This is called
sublimation.
This process is sublimation,
solid to vapor. This is called
ionization, gas phase species loses
an electron. That is the strict
definition of ionization.
So I am already there with sodium.
Now, chlorine I have to do a little
bit more heavy lifting here because
chlorine starts as a diatomic
molecule. The first thing I have to
do is bust that in half.
This is called dissociation.
I need to dissociate the chlorine.
And now I have to convert atomic
chlorine into ionic chlorine.
I am going to do that by adding an
electron. And this reaction here is
the inverse of ionization,
isn't it? Its ionization would be I
take one of the electrons on
chlorine and throw it away.
Here I am actually throwing an
electron onto chlorine.
So this reaction is called electron
affinity. You can think of electron
affinity as sort of the ionization
in reverse of the ion.
It is the minus.
It loses an ion.
And this reaction is what we call
crystallization.
Those are the five steps.
Let's see if we can find
information. I am going to call
this one. Let's see.
I think I labeled this one two,
ionization I labeled three, electron
affinity I labeled four and
crystallization I labeled five.
And thanks to Professor Hess, I can
now say that the total energy to
form sodium chloride should equal --
In other words,
delta H formation of sodium chloride
should be independent of paths.
I should be able to take the sum of
all of those delta Hs.
Oh, I'm using H. Forgive me.
This is the term enthalpy. It is
essentially equal to internal energy
for condensed systems,
but when you look in the books
sometimes they will use this term.
For a first pass,
let's just say for condensed systems
we can go with it.
We are going to take the sum of the
delta H's or the deltas H for all of
these little reactions.
Let's get some numbers here.
Let's see. This is called the
Born-Haber Cycle,
what I am showing you right now.
And this was put up by two people,
Max Born and Fritz Haber. Actually,
I put this up --
If you are interested in reading
about these people,
there is a Nobel prize website here
you can learn about all these guys.
This is Haber. He got the Nobel in
1918. He invented ammonia synthesis
with catalysis by iron.
A brilliant chemist. And Born
worked on a number of things,
including the Born exponent, and
taught himself crystallography sort
of as something to do during World
War I. And that is how come he got
involved in this,
because obviously this is talking
about crystal formation.
So that is why this is called the
Born-Haber Cycle.
Anyway, if you go to your Periodic
Table you will find that on the one
side you can get what is called the
enthalpy of atomization.
And that is this first term.
Delta H1 is enthalpy of atomization.
And if you look it up,
for sodium it is about 108
kilojoules per mole.
Actually, what I did was used a
different source so I have 107.
But that is OK. What's a kilojoule
between friends?
Number two is dissociation energy.
And dissociation energy is 122
kilojoules per mole.
And number three is ionization.
If you flip the Periodic Table over
you will have the ionization energy
of sodium, first ionization energy,
and it is about 5 eV which, when you
convert, is a whopping 496
kilojoules per mole.
This is looking bleak,
people. Look at this. I have three
out of the five energies,
and they are all positive.
This thing better start turning
negative soon or we are going to
change the way the world works here.
And I know that sodium chloride
forms because,
if I look on the webpage at 3.
91, you see this down here, this is
sodium in kerosene.
That is metallic sodium that would
keep in kerosene so it doesn't react
with the oxygen in the air.
And that is an Erlenmeyer flask
that has been filled with chlorine
and sodium has been added to it.
And there is the sodium chloride
crystal that forms between the two
of them. And,
because I looked at the website,
I know this reaction has a negative
number.
There is an interesting observation
about electronic structure,
by the way. Metallic sodium is
toxic to humans.
Chlorine gas, toxic to humans.
Electron transfer, we cannot live,
we die without sodium chloride. So
this tells you that it's electron
structure that governs.
Let's find some good news here.
Well, I have some good news.
Number four, electron affinity.
Chlorine has a high valence
electron energy.
It gobbles up electrons.
And that is a negative number.
That turns out to be negative 349.
That is for part four. And then
the last one, huge.
If you go to the Madelung
calculation, it is basically this
one over here.
Multiply by 1.
475 and you end up with minus 787
kilojoules per mole.
When you add this whole thing up,
it gives you a net of minus 411
kilojoules per mole or about
4 eV per ion pair.
Good. I was worried there.
That is the Born-Haber Cycle.
And the Born-Haber Cycle allows you
to see what the relative values of
the different energy components are.
Again, what's the utility of the
Born-Haber Cycle?
It deconvolves that reaction of
sodium plus chlorine into elementary
steps that are related to electron
transfer and acquisition.
That is the value of Born-Haber.
Here is a chart that just shows the
positive energies,
and you can see the various
components, and then the negative
energies and the net.
But look at the lattice energy,
the Madelung energy component is
huge which tells you that when ions
form they really want to continue to
glom onto one another and form that
giant crystal.
And so this is now a chart of just
a component number five,
the lattice energies.
Keep this number in mind,
787. Let's check. Here is sodium
plus chlorine.
It's 787. So that is one plus
against one minus.
But look at this one.
There is magnesium with oxygen.
That is 3,791. It is almost 4,000
kilojoules per mole.
And magnesium oxide has a melting
point of 2,800 degrees C.
Sodium chloride is about 801
degrees C. Aluminum oxide,
aluminum plus oxygen. Look at this.
Aluminum oxide almost 1,
00 kilojoules per mole. Alumina is
really stable,
which is why it takes so much energy
to make aluminum.
That is why aluminum is so
expensive because the oxide is so
stable. And why is it so stable?
Because aluminum ions have charge
of plus three and oxygen ions have
charge of minus two.
When you go into the Coulombic term
here, instead of one times one,
it's three times two. That is it.
So you want high temperature bricks,
what are you going to make them out
of? It's pretty obvious.
It's all here. It all falls out.
It is fantastic. And this is an
interesting thing.
This is ionic radii with a noble
gas configuration.
All of these have engaged in
electron transfer.
So, just to get your bearings,
there is our pal sodium plus.
Sodium plus is isoelectronic with
neon. It only has 10
electrons, not 11.
Magnesium 2 plus,
it is also isoelectronic with neon.
What do you see? You start with O
double minus, so that is oxygen plus
two electrons.
It is 1.45. Ten electrons again,
1.33. Ten electrons again. Ten
electrons again.
Ten electrons again.
What is happening? The same number
of electrons, but the number of
protons keeps going up,
up, up. The positive force of
attraction of the electrons on the
outside is greater and greater,
and that pulls everything in. And
so not only is aluminum highly
charged, but it is physically small.
It is tight, buff,
a lean, mean fighting machine.
It goes after oxygen because it is
small. It is a high charged density.
And likewise down here.
You see all of these. Look at
beryllium 2 plus,
very tiny, charge plus two.
Why do we need to know all of this?
I can take you and immediately
start designing batteries,
because we need ions in motion,
we need small ions in motion.
All of this stuff is related,
fantastic stuff. What you see is
that the radius changes with atomic
number for constant electron number.
Well, we are getting close. I
talked a lot about the exam so I
don't have a lot of time left to
talk about the structural metals.
I will just give you this one
little slide so you get a sense of
what we are up against.
Number one structural metal is
steel. Number two is aluminum.
Number three is magnesium.
Aluminum and magnesium are both made
by ionic liquid electrolysis,
just as I showed you last day.
But look at the tonnage differences.
Aluminum is 25 million tons per
year for the whole planet.
Magnesium was 60,000 tons.
Iron or steel, 800 million tons,
almost a billion tons of steel.
That is virgin metal.
That is not recycled.
And steel is the most recycled
material.
It sells for about 20 cents a pound,
so that represents about one-third
of a trillion dollars.
20 cents a pound. You build a
steel plant with a capital cost of
several billion dollars.
You bring iron ore from one part of
the planet, carbon,
limestone, you put it into this
reactor and you ship this all over
the world. Go to the grocery store
tonight. Tell me what you find on
the shelf that sells for 20 cents a
pound. This is amazing.
This is modern industrial chemistry
showing its strength.
Before you go, it is the weekend,
I will send you off with a joke. We
studied the Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle. The story goes
Heisenberg is giving a seminar.
He has a rental car and is zooming
to the airport.
He is doing 100 miles an hour down
the Mass Pike and gets pulled over
by a State Trooper.
The State Troopers says I want
title and registration.
He says, hey, buddy, where is the
fire? Do you know how
fast you were going?
And Heisenberg says,
no, but I know where I am.
Get out of here.